hello and welcome to your program 3abn
today Bible Q Anda my name is Evalia
deny and it's a privilege for me to
share this following hour with each one
of you and of course we have our 3ab and
family right here ready to attack all
those questions and comments that you
have sent in so we thank you and we
welcome you in jesus' name uh to my
right I have Daniel ping welcome thank
you I'm glad to be here and sure enough
we want to attack the questions with the
word of God Amen that is right and Jason
Bradley God bless you so good to see you
God bless you too it's great to be here
and I'm looking forward to diving into
these questions and finding the answers
in the word of God amen amen and John
deny welcome it's a blessing to be here
and again we want to thank everyone for
sending in their questions good
questions and it leads us to study God's
word deeper MH that's that's right and
some of you folks may have comments and
questions as well and I'm going to give
you right off the bat the contact
information because I don't want you to
forget that question that has been you
know in your mind for a few days already
and I got to remember to send it in well
guess what you can send it via text and
that number is 618 228
3975 618 228
3975 or if prefer email you can do so by
writing to Bible QA 3abn.org
and this is what the word of God said I
sought the Lord and he heard me and
delivered me from all my fears they
looked to him and were radiant and their
faces were not ashamed number eight says
oh taste and see that the Lord is good
amen
people blessed is the man who trusts in
him and you know what the Lord's word
the Bible is what's going to give you
encouragement trust in his word and no
need to fear Jesus is here the word of
God will cast out all fears so I want to
encourage you in Jesus this hour and
continue your journey and studying
there's no question too small no
question too big all the questions and
doubts that you may be facing are
important to the Lord and the Lord has
called these men of God to provide the
answer biblical answers so in order for
us to continue we'd like to go to the
Lord Lord in prayer I'm going to ask
John deny please to pray for us sure
let's go to the Lord in prayer our
wonderful and loving Heavenly Father we
thank you we thank you for providing the
holy scriptures we see in their
marvelous promises that you have made
yes we see prophecies that you have made
that have been fulfilled and some that
are to be fulfilled yes we take courage
in knowing that there is hope in Jesus
and during this moment that we are
together we ask for the blessing of your
Holy Spirit to give Bible answers we
pray for everyone that will be listening
watching we ask you to bless them as
well and that they will become more and
more interested to study the holy
scriptures we ask you for these
blessings in the holy and blessed name
of Jesus amen amen amen thank you very
much well folks we are ready to dive in
John sent in a text and we're going to
address this question ping are you ready
I'm ready here we go what does God say
about Christians eating mushrooms you
heard me right mushrooms all right a
simple straightforward question and love
them or hate them uh the Bible let's
start here the Bible does not say that
eating mushrooms is a sin but here's a
principle and it comes from an inspired
prayer written by John in in third John
1 ver2 and is that God wants us to be
healthy beloved I pray that you may
prosper in all things and be in Health
just as your soul prospers so God wants
us to live and he wants us to live
healthy now about two 2% of mushrooms if
you eat them they can actually kill you
so right off the top let's just say
those will not be healthy mushrooms then
there's another 2% of mushrooms that
they're considered Psy psychotropic or
hallucinogenic and so then they they
make it hard to think they make you
anxiety and paranoia and impaired
judgment so we'll just throw those right
out uh we want our brain in tip toop
shape now about four to 5% of mushroom
species are considered to be edible so
what about those ones so we'll begin the
biblical answer here with what God gave
to eat in the Garden of Eden in Genesis
1:29 and God said see I've given you
every herb that yields seed which is on
the face of all the Earth and every tree
whose fruit yields seed to you it shall
be food so in the Garden of Eden sinless
Perfection everything that we needed was
supplied through seed bearing plants and
so so the first principle of diet is
this make sure you are eating plenty of
those things that God has given us that
are good to eat it's not as much about
what you shouldn't eat but about what
you should be eating because if we're
not consuming the things that God has
given us to freely support our health it
really doesn't matter whether or not we
eat mushrooms because we're already
going to be jeopardizing our health by
not eating of the good things God has
given so now what is a mushroom it is a
fungus with spores it is not a seed a
plant with seeds it's usually grown in
dark moist places on dead and decaying
things which makes us pause and wonder
here uh in in the Garden of Eden
mushrooms were not necessary because
remember God had given everything that
was necessary supplied through plants
but those who study mushrooms tell us
that there are some useful properties
that are available if we consume
mushrooms some people use them as a meat
substitute some as a minor source of
protein they're low in calories sodium
and fat but you certainly could prepare
them in such a way that they would be
high in sodium calories or fat uh they
can also be a limited source of some
vitamins including vitamin D if grown
under the right lighting conditions and
they are a source of the antioxidant uh
ergine which can slow cellular damage
but all these potential good things out
of mushrooms can come through seed
bearing plants as well there are
specific commands in Leviticus 11 that
tell us there there are certain animals
that absolutely under no condition are
we to eat and this includes all
scavenger animals and some people see
and here's the reason for the question
some people see this principle applying
to mushrooms as well but there is no
command telling us not to eat mushrooms
they are not called unclean or an
abomination in fact they're not referred
to in the Bible at all so here's the
principle you can apply from God's word
do eat a good variety of fresh healthy
fruits nuts vegetables grains things
like that
and then pray and ask God to instruct
you God knows you better than I do he
knows what ought to go into your body
talk to him and finally God wants you to
be healthy so if mushrooms make you sick
don't eat them uh if you already have
fungal issues that you're dealing with
internally or on the skin consuming more
fungus probably will not be helpful for
getting rid of those fungal issues and
if you have digestive gut issues uh
consuming fungi can contribute to yeast
overgrowth in the intestines so there's
no command regarding mushrooms search
for the good word uh from God and then
do what is necessary to live a life of
Health to honor god wow amen very
educational thank you now Jason Bradley
this one for you and I I have to read a
little message here it's Anonymous okay
okay this is Jason this is a follow-up
question for you from my previous Q&A
the anonymous viewer states that the
first use of L magic is what caused our
world its problem Genesis 3:6 she Eve
saw that the tree was beautiful and its
fruit looked delicious and she had told
she had been told by one of God's
creations that it would give her wisdom
it certainly had done that for the
serpent it seemed because he was
speaking unlike any of the other
creatures so logically it was the right
thing to try it right H tell us wrong
but it was an act of Disobedience that
caused our world this immense problem
let's begin by looking at Genesis 2:
16-1 17 and the Lord God commanded the
man saying of every tree of the garden
you may freely eat but of the tree of
the knowledge of Good and Evil you shall
not eat for in the day that you eat of
it you shall surely die so what happened
Genesis 3:
1-5 now the serpent was more cunning
than any beast of the field which the
Lord God had made and he said to the
woman has God indeed said You shall not
eat of every tree of the garden and the
woman said to the serpent we may eat the
fruit of the Trees of the garden but of
the fruit of the tree which is in the
midst of the garden God has said You
shall not eat it nor shall you touch it
touch it lest you die then the serpent
said to the woman you shall not surely
die for God knows that in the day you
eat of it your eyes will be opened and
you will be like God knowing good and
evil according to
dictionary.com the word cunning means
crafty and shrewd especially in
deception now let's look at Genesis 3: 6
so when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food that it was pleasant to
the eyes and a tree desirable to make
one wise she took of its fruit and ate
she also gave to her husband with her
and he ate now nowhere in the Bible does
it say that the serpent ate the fruit
and that's what made him wise um the
serpent was the first medium that Satan
used uh and how do we know this well we
can look at Revelation 12:
7-9 and war broke out in heaven Michael
and his angels fought with the dragon
and the dragon and his angels fought but
they did not Prevail nor was a place
found for them in heaven any longer so
the Great Dragon was cast out get this
that Serpent of old called the devil and
Satan who
deceives the whole world he was cast to
the Earth and his angels were cast out
with him now you remember what we said
about the word cunning how you know it's
the definition was uh it means crafty
and shud especially in deception and
here we see the serpent of old called
the devil and Satan who deceives the
whole world so in the beginning when
Adam and Eve were in the garden and the
serpent was speaking with Eve that was
the devil speaking through the serpent
to Eve to get her to disobey God and I
find it really interesting that he
approached Eve first you know
considering the fact that Eve would be
carrying the seed so you know he
appealed to the to the woman first who
would be carrying the seed all
throughout the Bible you can see
different instances where the devil
tries to attack the seed and we see that
in our world today where the devil is
trying to you know go go on about things
through abortion and all of these things
he wants to attack the
seed to sum it all up though it's never
logical to disobey our omniscient
omnipresent omnipotent God it's never
never never ever Works in our favor to
go against God we serve a powerful God
that knows the end from the beginning
and he tells us these things for a
reason and so no matter what anybody
else says we need to stay true to the
word of God stand firm on the principles
contained in his word and live those
principles out in our life never disobey
God amen amen never disobey God and you
know what the Bible also says I can do
all things through Christ strengthens me
so we have that strength thank you Jason
Bradley now we're going to go to John
deny John deny all right this is from
Mark from Illinois he sent in a text he
says Jesus was baptized in the name of
the Father the Son the and holy spirit
later the disciples used the Father the
Son and the Holy Ghost Jesus said Spirit
not ghost so is it the Holy Spirit or
the Holy Ghost what what I'm sorry was
Ghost man's addition to the word of God
mark from Illinois sent that text in
well thank you Mark it is a good
question why is there a difference why
is there why are there two different
ways of saying the Holy Spirit uh it is
not necessarily man's addition to God's
word uh we have to keep in mind the time
frame when the King James version was
translated because it is really the King
James version that has Holy Spirit and
Holy Ghost the translations that came
afterwards they use the word the phrase
holy spirit so let's look at the time
during that
time uh the word ghost did not mean what
it means today today when you say ghost
people think oh somebody that's died and
has come back and it's uh transparent
and it's this a person is walking around
uh scaring people uh you said
transparent is it invisible did you mean
yes transparent invisible type of being
that has died and come back this is the
idea of ghost today but in those days it
was uh meant an immaterial material
being not necessarily a ghost as we see
it today so words change meaning as time
goes on and when you look at the way the
King James version was translated it was
translated by about 47 Scholars
separated into six companies and
actually
one uh the the people the group that was
assigned some of the books they uh
translated Holy Ghost every instance you
saw the word Hagan numma while the other
group another committee was translating
other books with the Holy Spirit and so
when they come together to discuss these
things because of the words not really
meaning ghost as they do today it was
acceptable to them and that's why you
have that it was not necessary that it
was a ill intent to bring the word holy
ghost in there so uh this helps us to
understand that uh there's really no uh
ill intent in putting in Holy Spirit and
Holy Ghost and today we understand
better Holy Spirit than Holy Ghost it is
uh we consider a
better understanding or a better
translation to say holy spirit
especially since the word has changed in
meaning when you think of children in
this respect and you say holy ghost it
may mean something different to them uh
because of the way they have been
brought up so I would say to you don't
look at it as uh something
sneaky or deceiving that people put in
but rather that words have changed in
meaning as time goes on oh very good I I
do hear some people say he got the Holy
Ghost you know it's a term very common
yes among Christians they know that
we're referring to the Holy Spirit uh a
member of the godhead so it's not an
issue but for people coming into the
church new they they're going to have
some concerns or not fully understand
that thank you so much JY so nice to
always hear you okay we're going to go
to
Daniel now this question comes in for
Margaret from Indiana and it says
according to the Bible why are some fish
better for us to eat than others all
right this sounds somewhat similar to
the last question on mushrooms and let's
go to Leviticus 11: 9 to 12 I'm just
going to read verse 9 and 12 but here's
where we find the instructions regarding
what we eat from what swims or or lives
in the water
these you may eat of all that are in the
water whatever in the water has fins and
scales whatever in the sea or in the
rivers that you may eat uh verse 12
whatever in the water does not have fins
or scales that shall be an Abomination
to you so here's the basic principle
fins and scales you could eat no fins
and scales don't eat so God gives us a
command here but you'll notice something
is missing to our eyes why it doesn't
tell us why and he didn't tell them why
uh but he told them what they needed to
know and so we see in this principle a
couple of things can we and will we
trust God based on what he says and then
God wants us to live a healthy life he
desires Purity for us both physically
and spiritually now he's he's given us
the god-given ability to study his world
of creation today so we know uh the why
and the why is this the things we
consume affect us uh because plant and
animal kingdoms are different if we were
to consume plants the disease in Plants
will generally speaking not transfer
their disease to us but disease and
animals that we consume will transfer to
us cancer and meats will be transferred
to those who consume it and this is why
even in zoos they have to protect
animals from diseases from humans and
vice versa anything that does not have
fish and scales in the water is more
likely to carry diseases that if we
consume them those diseases will be
transferred to us fins and scales right
fins and scales I don't not sure what I
said fish and scales fins and scales and
so in Leviticus 11 this is more than
just about uh uh about moral cleanliness
it's about our health as well so
swimming things that do not have fish
fins and scales sharks catfish whales
seahorse Rays eels these are predators
and scavengers meaning that they eat
other animals which often times are
already dead decaying or sick and they
consume those things and those disease
then is transferred into that animal and
then into us who would eat it now things
on the ground like crabs or Lobster
shrimp or oyster starfish these feed on
stuff that falls to the bottom of the
ocean you have dead things and you have
the waste or excent product uh products
of other animals and so as you can
imagine that kind of diet does not
produce a clean healthy flesh and so we
see this same principle in birds in the
air and animals foragers were considered
clean scavengers that eat dead rotting
material were unclean and unhealthy so
the lesson is this God did not give the
reasons there but he said trust me now
we know the reasons and so so you and I
have even greater Foundation to say we
can trust God to do whatever he asks us
even if we don't yet know the reason why
because God loves us it is in his will
that we do our part to cooperate him by
eating the things that produce a good
healthy diet so we can have a good
healthy mind to follow him amen amen and
there may be folk out there saying I've
been eating all that stuff and I'm not
say God and His Mercy has kept them
right but but now we know truth and this
is biblical truth Jason Bradley here we
go we received an email and this one is
for you to answer if no child of mine
returns to the Adventist Christian faith
will Jesus do to me as he did to the Fig
Tree I believe you were referring to
what happened in Matthew chap 21: 18- 22
and Luke chap no Mark excuse me Mark 11:
:
12-14 uh let's look at the account found
in Matthew 21:
18-22 now in the morning as he returned
to the city he was hungry and seeing a
fig tree by the road he came to it and
found nothing on it but leaves and said
to it let no fruit grow on you ever
again immediately the Fig Tree withered
away now here's the lesson of the the
withered fig tree verse 20 and when the
disciples saw it they marveled saying
how did the Fig Tree wither away so soon
Jesus answered them answered and said to
them assuredly I say to you if you have
faith and do not doubt you will not only
do what was done to the Fig Tree but
also if you say to this mountain be
removed and cast into the sea it will be
done and whatever things you ask in
prayer believing you will receive so
that sit situation doesn't apply to you
as a parent here are a few things I want
you to consider it's important to
remember that as parents you can
influence your child's upbringing but
each individual makes their own choices
the Bible offers guidance on parenting
and individual responsibility Proverbs
22:6 says train up a child in the way he
should go and when he is old he will not
depart from it is Ezekiel 18: 20 the
soul who sins shall die the son shall
not bear the guilt of the father nor the
father bear the guilt of the son the
righteousness of the righteous shall be
upon himself and the wickedness of the
wicked shall be upon himself each person
is accountable for their own choices and
actions now while you may have guided
your children um they ultimately May
make their own decisions you will not be
punished for your children's Behavior
God understands that each person has
free will after all he gave us he
created us as free moral agents um and
he knows that you know we will make our
own choices but as parents you can
continue to pray for them support them
and be uh offer support I should say you
don't want to affirm them in their
wrongdoing let me make that very clear
um but you know and be an example Le of
Christ love and that's what you can do
as a parent keep trusting in God and
seeking his guidance I would also
encourage you to study up on the
character of God we serve a loving God I
want to share this with you ever so
quickly Jeremiah chap 29: 11 through uh
11 and 12 for I know the thoughts that I
think toward you says the Lord thoughts
of peace and not of evil to give you a
future and a hope then you will call
upon me and go and pray to me and I will
will listen to
you God wants he he thinks great
thoughts about you and he loves you very
much and he loves your children and
wants to spend eternity with them even
more than you want them to spend
eternity with him amen so I pray that
you find great comfort in that yeah amen
thank you Jason that was beautiful bless
my heart too as a mother okay John deny
are you ready Oh by God's grace you
better be ready here we go time is
taking so we're going to go to Matthew
53 this is what um Lindsay from Canada
she sent the email in and it says in
Matthew 5:3 what does it mean when it
says blessed are those who are poor in
spirit for theirs is the Kingdom of
Heaven what does poor in spirit mean l
say wants to know thank you very much um
I first want to say that it's not saying
that you are blessed if you are poor in
the sense of you have nothing uh we
don't want people to think that uh well
it's it's a sin to be rich because it's
not a sin to be rich the Bible talks
about that the love of money is the root
of all evil but here blessed are the
poor in spirit is talking about those
that understand that we have all sinned
and come short of the glory of God we
all need Jesus to recognize that we need
the Lord is to be poor in spirit in the
sense of we know that we need the Lord
every day every moment of the hour and
so this is what it means to be poor in
spirit you recognize you need the Lord
and you uh as you continue looking unto
Jesus the author and finisher of our
faith you see that he wants to transform
you into his likeness and as you look at
yourself you see that you need him to
become like him so the to be poor and
spirit is to to recognize your need and
this is why I point to James 4:10 humble
yourselves in the sight of the Lord and
He Shall lift you up so we need to
understand that as we humble ourselves
in the sight of the lord we are poor in
spirit and we need the Lord uh also you
see there in James chapter 4:8 draw nigh
or near to God and He will draw near to
you recognize your need of the Lord and
understand that he is calling you draw
you to come close to him this does not
mean that you say poor in spirit that
you're always lamenting oh I am just so
wicked so sinful so and you keep and you
and this uh condition or saying this is
not a sin to say that uh but to remain
in this oh I am just I can't even
approach the Lord which is true Paul you
remember uh Paul saying I am the chief
of Sinners but he also recognized that
With God all things are possible that's
why he said um I can do all things
through Christ who strengthens me to be
poor in spirit in in the sense of
drawing you to the Lord this is what is
is talking about here so we encourage
you to continue drawing close to the
Lord and to always see your need of the
Lord every day amen amen all right well
I know you're excited and you're
thankful to the Lord for these Bible
answers but you know let's think about
those that have not sent in their
questions you can send in your questions
by text
sending it to 618 228
3975 618 228
3975 also email works 24 hours as well
Bible QA
3abn.org
abnor official we await your comments
and your questions let's move on to
Daniel ping Daniel there's a text and it
says why do people say that Jesus is all
knowing and he knows everything but they
say that when Satan came to him in the
wilderness he did not know who Satan was
at first until he spoke why didn't Jesus
know who Satan was before he spoke okay
all right Jesus is God
with every attribute of God and every
divine power of God John 1:1 so clear
speaking of Jesus in the beginning was
the word that is Jesus and the Word was
with God and the Word was God but
there's more to the story Romans 8:3
Jesus came in the likeness of sinful
flesh in Hebrews 2:17 therefore in all
things he had to be made like his
Brethren like us Philippians 2:6 and
seven Jesus did not consider it robbery
to be equal with God but made himself of
no reputation taking the form of a
bonder servant and coming in the
likeness of men he didn't grasp and hold
on to that Divine brightness of glory
and the divine power and for knowledge
here's the simple answer Jesus set those
Divine attributes and Powers aside so
that he could face sin just like one of
us he passed through infancy and
toddlerhood and Adolescence at every
stage learning and growing Luke 2:52
says that Jesus increased in wisdom and
stature he's growing he accepted the
constraints of of and the limitations of
humanity he faced the same temptations
that all Humanity faces with the same
weakened body and brain power and yet he
had access to the same Divine gifts that
you and I may receive and he was
Victorious and here are those gifts Luke
2:40 speaking of Jesus says that as a
child he grew and became strong in
spirit filled with wisdom and the grace
of God was upon Him Grace is not just
forgiveness of sin Jesus had no sin it
is God's power to live without sin
Ephesians 4:7 says but to each one of us
Grace was given we have that too Luke 4
ver1 says that Jesus was filled with the
Holy Spirit and then he was led by the
spirit which we too who can be and so
Jesus sets an example for us that we can
follow by living in the constraints of
humanity so how did Jesus recognize
Satan the same way you and I can
recognize him Matthew 3 ends like this
Jesus is baptized and then God the
father says this is my beloved Son in
whom I'm well pleased chapter four Satan
comes along and he says if you are the
Son of God and Jesus immediately knows
because of the grace that God has given
him filled with the spirit and the
testimony of God's Own word this is a
liar now Satan comes to us and he
doesn't give us that lie if you're the
Son of God he says things like this God
couldn't possibly love someone like you
and so using the same power in God's
word we go to John 1 John 3:1 behold
what manner of love the father has loved
us that we should be called children of
God you're a liar Satan Satan says you
could never overcome sin 1 Corinthians
15:57 says but thanks be to God who
gives us the victory through our Lord
Jesus Christ and so we have access to
the same power that Jesus did the grace
of God the Holy Spirit and the word of
God to give us Victory amen amen amen
grace of God Holy Spirit and he gives us
the victory you church amen I could
listen to Bing all day all right guys
here we go uh Jason Bradley this one for
you and vanessia from New York sent in a
text and I read I am watching 3abn Bible
Q&A and heard a question from an
Adventist wife asking how to observe the
sabbath when her husband watches TV well
I am sort of having similar issues
however my husband leaves me in the room
to watch Church online and do my worship
he acknowledges the Sabbath even got
baptized a few weeks ago but still say
he doesn't believe in church or
denomination what am I
doing what am I doing is just praying
that the same way the Holy Spirit
prompted him to get baptized at The
Crusade it will also speak to him and
show him the importance of church let me
know if I need to do otherwise how can I
encourage my husband to attend church on
Sabbath well thank you for your your
your question uh Venia um prayer
patience and persistence is key for
prayer and persistence let's look at uh
what Jesus said in Matthew 7: 7
to8 ask and it will be given to you seek
and you will find knock and it will be
open to you for everyone who asks
receives and he who seeks finds and to
him who knocks it will be opened the
important thing is that we ask according
to God's Will and here's what I know
about God he desires a relationship with
your husband and he wants to spend
eternity with him in the Kingdom of
Heaven now I'm not sure what your
situation is personally but if you can
physically attend church then you should
do so instead of staying in the room and
watching it on TV and all of that stuff
you need to be with the Brethren um
Hebrews 10: 24 to 25 says and let us
consider one another in order to stir up
love and good works not forsaking the
assembling of ourselves together as is
the manner of some but exhorting one
another and so much the more as you see
the day approaching it's so important
for believers to come together to
encourage one another and worship God
together Colossians 3:1 16 let the word
of Christ dwell in you richly in all
wisdom teaching and admonishing one
another in Psalms and hymns and
spiritual songs singing with Grace in
your hearts to the Lord where does that
take place it takes place at church go
to church when we get together in church
it allows for the sharing of God's word
and spiritual growth through teaching
and encouragement I go to church and I
hear things and I'm like whoa I never
saw it that way before I I never knew
that and I go and I learn iron sharpens
iron be patient with your
husband as God is still working on his
heart a major thing for your husband to
consider is the fact that Jesus went to
church he was in the synagogue on
Sabbath as was his custom he was
teaching and preaching and all of those
things and so as followers of Christ as
Christians we should be followers of
Christ Christ that's what we're supposed
to do and so we look at Christ's example
that he set and he was in church um one
thing I would encourage you to do too is
check out a sermon that P that Ryan Day
gave uh it was at the Thompsonville 7th
Day Adventist Church and it was called
not a fan powerful powerful message and
it will really open your eyes to some
things please sit down with your husband
and spend that time together watching
that message and I hope to see you guys
in church amen amen thank you Jason all
right now Jan deny I have an email here
from Brian okay so it's a little lengthy
but here we go is it a sin to be an
artist I read the second commandment
Thou shalt not make unto thee any Graven
image or any likeness of anything that
is in heaven above or that is in the
earth beneath or that is in the water
under or is in the water under the Earth
Thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve them I enjoyed drawing and
painting people environment and animals
I thought about starting to make
children's picture books I feel this is
a gift that God has given me but if it
is a sin I will stop Brian from email I
sent it through email and such a sincere
uh question yes I I see that as well and
I uh want to commend you for um looking
at the commandment and wondering if what
you are doing is a sin and also showing
the willingness to stop if you
understand that is a sin I praise the
Lord for that and so I want to answer
this in a way that uh I pray will be a
hope to you uh it is not a sin to be an
artist if you are not making things to
be worshiped or for people to bow down I
will give you some examples as we find
in the scriptures uh notice in Exodus
chapter
25 uh I'm going to
read uh Verse 18 and thou shalt make two
cherubims of gold of beaten work shalt
thou make them in the two ends of the
mercy seat and make one cherub on on the
one on the one end and the other cherub
on the other end even of The Mercy Seat
shall you make the cherubims on the two
ends thereof so this is talking about
making an image of angels that were
inside the most holy place they were not
to be objects of worship they were
images made of gold so we see here an
example that artists or people that had
the ability to make these things were
utilized in to make this for the
Tabernacle specifically in the most holy
place also talking also about the
sanctuary uh in Exodus chapter 26 I read
verse one moreover Thou shalt make the
Tabernacle with 10 curtains of twined
linen and blue and purple and Scarlet
with cherubims of cunning work shalt
thou make them Exodus
26:31 and thou shalt make a ve taale of
blue and purple and Scarlet and fine
twine linen of cunning work with
cherubims shall be made and also you can
see the same type of thought in Exodus
36:8 so these were uh embroidered uh on
the curtains uh these likeness of angels
but they they were not to be worshiped
they were not to bow down before the
before them it it was for the purpose of
illustration for people to understand uh
that God has Holy Angels and so uh yes
as we look at these things we can
conclude that there is a use for artist
making things that will draw people to
the Lord or will bring honor and glory
to the Lord but not to uh cause people
to Bow Down and Worship the uh images or
things that are made because of the
ability God has given you you recognize
it as a gift from God use it to God's
glory amen amen God's an artist God's an
artist and even nothing he made was to
be worshiped that's right that's right
that's right amen thank
you that was wonderful okay we're gonna
go to Danel ping and CLA sent in a text
and you get to answer his question it
says how old was Daniel when he was
taken to Babylon and when he was in the
Lion's Den I feel I feel a closeness to
Daniel sharing the same name I'm
thankful my parents for giv me that name
amen how old was he when he uh passed
that test and then the later test the
one in Daniel 1 and then the one in
Daniel 6 and there's lessons to be
learned in here first of all the purpose
of Babylon in taking Daniel and and
those they that they took with him was
to re-educate them so they're not going
to take old people who only have a few
years left of the investment that
Babylon is going to put into them so we
know that he was young in fact verse
four of chapter 1 says that they were
young men which means they were older
than 13 because anything younger than
that would have been considered a child
but they were also old enough to
determine that Daniel and his friends
were somebody who had potential also in
verse four they were gifted in all
wisdom possessing knowledge and quick to
understand who had ability to serve in
the king's Palace and so they had
already uh distinguished themselves in
that way age 15 in the Jewish economy
was the age when you'd be considered
usually for rabinal school so Daniel we
know is at least in his later teens now
chapter 1: 21 says that Daniel continued
until the reign of Cyrus the Persian in
chapter 10 verse one makes it clearer in
the third year of Cyrus King of Persia a
message was given to Daniel So Daniel
was taken captive in 605 BC we know that
from historical records along with the
Bible and the third year of Cyrus uh of
the Persian was one was 536 BC so that's
69 years later so teens to at least 69
years later and this this timeline
confirms that he was a young man a teen
the Bible doesn't give us a specific age
so picture a young man of about 18 still
uh young enough to have life before him
and yet old enough to be able to make
commitments and convictions toward God
now this means that Daniel grew up under
the later years of the reign of King
Josiah in Israel so he benefited from
all the spiritual reforms begun by
Josiah who discovered the book of the
law and Daniel likely grew up under
eventually the influence of prophets
like habach and Jeremiah and nahm and
Zephaniah and he knew about the prophecy
that Isaiah had given to to Hezekiah in
Isaiah 39:7 and they shall take away
some of your sons who will descend from
you whom you will beget and they shall
be Unix in the Palace of the king of
Babylon so this impression upon Daniel's
mind of searching the word of God and
the tragedy of Josiah's death really
impressed his mind the lesson for our
world today is that the teen uh the
world SE sees the teen years as kind of
like a waiting room where you just kind
of goof off and Mill around until the
real life and and things begin but the
teen years are the time for young men
and women to develop strong convictions
for God that will not be moved
Ecclesiastes 12:1 remember now the
Creator in the days of your youth
Daniel's convictions were in place in
his teen years now Daniel 6 the the
Lion's Den happened in the first year of
Darius when the Babylonian empire fell
to the pers
539 BC so that is 66 years after Daniel
1 this means Daniel was likely in his
early 80s if he was taken captive at age
18 then he's 84 years old then when he's
thrown into the lion's den and so the
lesson here stand firm to the end all
right Daniel didn't say I've proven
myself I'm done I've paid my dues
Matthew 24:13 says he who endures to the
end shall be saved God cares about the
beginning and the end times of our life
amen
glory to God thank you okay we have an
email here and uh Jason Bradley huh if
we don't want Jesus's forgiveness he
doesn't forgive us then why should I
forgive someone who doesn't want my
forgiveness the short answer is because
you're a Christian um forgiveness is
critical in our journey as Christians
and I'm not answering this question from
a judgmental uh standpoint or anything
like that so I want to make that very
clear where my heart is but as as
Christians we're called to live above
the standard of the world and live for
Christ Jesus said in Matthew chap 6
verse 14 and 15 for if you forgive men
their trespasses your heavenly father
will also forgive you but if you do not
forgive men their trespasses neither
will your father forgive your trespasses
I want to be forgiven of my trespasses
how about you the ministry of
reconciliation is our responsibility 2
Corinthians 5: 17- 20 therefore if
anyone is in Christ he is a new creation
old things have passed away behold all
things have become new now all things
are of God who has reconciled us to
himself through Jesus Christ and has
given us the ministry of
reconciliation that is that God was in
Christ reconciling the world to himself
not imputing their trespasses to them
and has committed to us the word of
reconciliation now then we are
ambassadors for Christ as though God
were pleading through us we implore you
on Christ behalf be reconciled to God
forgiveness can be a powerful tool for
personal healing holding on to anger and
resentment can be detrimental to your
own well-being being um but forgiving
someone even if they don't seek it can
help you release negative emotions and
find peace you know in response to your
statement if we if we don't want his
forgiveness Jesus doesn't forgive us
look we need Jesus's forgiveness we
can't survive without his forgiveness if
we want to spend eternity with him we
have to recognize our sinful State and
the mistakes that we've made confess our
sins to Christ he's faithful and just to
forgive us our sins to cleanse us from
all
unrighteousness and um you can find that
in 1 John
1:9 but yeah we we need to forgive
others whether they want it or not we
treat others not how they treat us but
how we would want to be treated we're
Christians regardless of whether someone
else acts like they
aren't wow thank you so much all
biblical answers and God help us all all
right John deny this is your last
question and we're going to go right to
it praise the Lord from Uganda Uganda we
received this email from Samuel so
greetings to Samuel and family it says
in reference to 1 Corinthians 7:15 what
does it mean by a brother or sister is
not under bondage in such cases what
bondage is being referred to is it all
related to Romans 7 1-4 if yes how and
if so if no why Samuel wants to
know thank you Samuel um you can examine
the contents of both and see that they
have some relations although not
directly uh meaning that this is what's
being discussed there are some
similarities let's go ahead and start in
First Corinthians chap 7: 13- 15 to get
a little context of this idea of of a
brother or sister is not under bondage
in such cases uh we start in verse 13
and the woman which had an husband that
believeth not and if he be pleased to
dwell with her let her not leave him so
that's a case uh part number one uh that
you have here for the unbelieving
husband is Sanctified by the wife and
the unbelieving wife is Sanctified by
the husband else were your children
unclean but now are they holy so we have
a situation here in which I want to say
this this is not um contradicting what
it says in I think it's 2 Corinthians
chapter 6 where it says do not be
unequally yolked with unbelievers so
this is not giving license to say go
look for somebody that is an unbeliever
and be with them this is a situation
where a person that they were together
and one became a Christian this doesn't
say oh you're not a Christian out of the
house house mhm so this is not what it's
talking about here this is talking about
a person converted after they are
married but one accepts and one does not
now verse 15 as you say but if the
unbelieving depart let him depart a
brother or a sister is not under bondage
in such cases but God hath called us to
peace so knowing this and putting this
together with Romans chapter 7 I'm just
going to read verse one and two for
because of time know ye not brethren for
I speak to them that know the law how
that the law hath dominion over a man as
long as he liveth for the woman which
hath an husband is bound by the law to
her husband so long as he liveth but if
the husband be there she is loose from
the law of her husband so what does it
mean to be under bondage if you if if
the woman is a Christian and the other
the husband is not and he says you know
this is not for me this is not my
lifestyle I rather not be with you I am
leaving she's not then obligated she's
not to compel him no no you got to stay
with me I am bound to you uh until you
die you need to you know she's not to
obligated to try to convince the man to
stay he wants to leave let him leave uh
so that's why you can live in peace
knowing that okay he left of his own
accord I didn't drive him to leave I
didn't uh coers him to leave I'm
practicing my Christian Life and uh he
chose not to be a part of it so you're
not obligated to say uh well I am bound
to the law uh bound to be compel him to
live to live under the conditions he
wants to leave he he's free to leave so
this is the idea of not being in bondage
you feel at peace knowing that you have
done what you're supposed to do and now
you can be at peace amen amen well time
is up and we're going to go to a pause
and we will be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org 5 that's
6182280065 to figure that out in their
life right now and for me personally uh
going to church each week is such a
blessing I can hear sermons on the
internet which are great but the
fellowship of Believers is such a
blessing God has given to us I encourage
you to find a church family amen Jason
amen I just want you to know that Jesus
loves you he wants to spend eternity
with you he's got he thinks great things
about you and he longs to spend that
time with you um you know if you have
sin in your life which we all do
you need to go to him repent confess
your sins he's faithful and just forgive
you of your sins and cleanse you from
all unrighteousness amen amen and joh
deny would you know I'm looking at James
chapter 4:7 which says submit yourselves
therefore to God resist the devil he
will flee from you so uh we see this
that we all have a need to submit to God
and the following verse says draw near
to God and He will draw draw near to you
in these times that we are living we all
need to draw near to God and the promise
is that He will draw near to you so I
want to encourage you if you feel poor
in spirit whatever your condition is if
you feel you have sinned draw near to
God He will draw near to you hallelujah
thank you Lord well friends at home
you're welcome to share this program and
all the programs in social media with
your friends put it on that wall share
it to your contact on your phone and
thank than you for tuning in God bless
you as you continue to study his word
see you next
[Music]
time